[Aplausos]
[Música]
creo que hay una cosa en la que todos
vamos a estar de acuerdo
internet ha cambiado nuestra forma de
vida
[Música]
m
tanto que según las estadísticas el 65
por ciento de los españoles o casi tres
de cada cuatro estadounidenses no pueden
imaginarse hecha la vida sin internet
servicios de música de noticias de
compras y sobre todo de vídeo como por
ejemplo esta plataforma youtube todo
este ingente volumen de datos amigos no
hace más que crecer y crecer
y ojo según las estimaciones de fisco
tan solo en los próximos 5 años eeuu
multiplicará por tres su tráfico de
internet de hecho ya en 2015 eeuu
alcanzó y pasó a corea del sur-
convirtiéndose en el líder mundial en
consumo per cápita de datos
y por supuesto internet este gran mundo
virtual cada vez está más integrado en
la vida de todos nosotros y supone una
mayor parte de la actividad económica
así que con todo esto ya os podéis
imaginar dos cosas
la primera la enorme cantidad de
infraestructuras que todo este consumo
está demandando y la segunda lo
importante que resulta la propia
regulación de internet pues bien el
pasado 14 de diciembre de 2017 la
comisión federal de comunicaciones de
eeuu como una decisión que creo bien
podemos calificar de histórica por su
trascendencia y sobre todo por su
controversia amigos como seguro ya
sabéis esta comisión decidió por tres
votos contra dos poner punto y final a
la llamada neutralidad de la red
james tuvo que abandonar la web
una regulación que fue aprobada en 2015
a petición del propio presidente obama
si la neutralidad nació en 2015 en poco
tiempo twitter los medios de
comunicación y prácticamente cualquier
espacio de debate vio difundir un
mensaje estamos ante el final de
internet tal y como lo conocemos por
cierto este hombre es allí para el
presidente de la comisión federal de las
comunicaciones y el gran protagonista de
toda esta historia
whitesides es el ministro esto
porque vélez fue muy extraordinaria y
knights también probablemente es una de
las personas más odiadas de internet
pues bien creo que hay un par de
preguntas que tenemos que contestar en
qué consistía fundamentalmente esta
regulación que supone realmente este
cambio
[Música]
mira básicamente en 2015 se decidió que
internet pasará de estar regulado por el
título primero de la ley de
comunicaciones a estarlo por el título
segundo pero qué diantres significa todo
esto pues para que nos entendamos
podemos decir que con este cambio
internet o sea la provisión del servicio
pasó a ser considerado como un servicio
público y a estar fuertemente regulado
por el gobierno en este caso por la
comisión federal de las comunicaciones
a ver si vinieron
en una regulación que entre otras cosas
impedía que las operadoras
estadounidenses como por ejemplo comcast
verizon o haití en ti pudieran por un
lado bloquear o ralentizar a su antojo
el tráfico de ciertos espacios web o
aplicaciones y por otro lado impedir que
dieran preferencia a otros proveedores
de contenido
nochebuena
jason network access to website
imaginaos por ejemplo el caso de una
compañía que decide dar preferencia a
netflix por encima de hb o también por
ejemplo a una compañía que le diga a
spotify que va a tener que pagar si
quiere que sus clientes puedan hacer uso
de sus servicios de música en
'streaming' alta
con esta regulación las compañías
tampoco podían cobrar cuotas que no
incluyese en el acceso a alguno de los
servicios imaginemos por ejemplo una
empresa que quiere una conexión de alta
velocidad pero que no consume videos de
netflix o hb o no importa con la
regulación anterior tenía que pagar por
el servicio completo las compañías las
operadoras no podían ofrecerle unas
tarifas sin mezcla
sin embargo amigos ahora todo esto ha
terminado en eeuu las compañías ahora
pueden determinar libremente sus tarifas
por ejemplo ofreciendo una tarifa de
acceso a internet que no incluya el
poder ver vídeos en 4k ojo no quiere
decir que lo vayan a hacer pero
probablemente sí que veamos aparecer
tarifas muy diferentes pues bien esto es
lo que hizo que las redes se incendiaran
con esta polémica decisión
[Música]
tan polémica que tan solo 107 de los 239
congresistas republicanos en la cámara
de representantes han hecho público su
apoyo a esta decisión pero pensáis que
todo esto está mal o creéis que internet
ya no será lo mismo pues he esperado un
momento
nada
una amenaza contra internet
[Aplausos]
en primer lugar veamos las sombras los
motivos por los que los defensores de la
neutralidad en la red consideran que
este cambio es tan negativo creo que
estos puntos son con diferencia los más
conocidos así que tampoco nos vamos a
detener mucho
a los detractores del cambio impulsado
por el partido republicano sostienen sus
posiciones en dos argumentos clave
primero que como las operadoras ahora
podrán cobrar extras tanto a las
empresas como a los clientes el coste de
internet va a subir y muchas pequeñas
empresas y start-up no van a poder
competir con las más grandes porque no
van a poder pagar un acceso preferente
segundo porque supone el fin de la
libertad sobre la que se construyó
internet imaginemos que una operadora
decide reducir la velocidad o incluso
bloquear el acceso a un medio de
comunicación
teóricamente es algo que podría ocurrir
nuestra economía de internet es la
envidia del mundo porque está abierta a
todos esta propuesta es un ataque a esa
apertura da a los proveedores de banda
ancha el poder de decidir qué voces
amplificar y sitios podemos visitar qué
conexiones podemos establecer y qué
comunidades crear disminuye el acceso
frena las oportunidades y censura el
contenido bueno todo esto es bien
conocido son los argumentos que
básicamente se han utilizado en la
de los medios de comunicación sin
embargo amigos ya sabéis que aquí en
visual político nos gusta buscar un
poquito más allá así que vamos a ello
[Música]
las luces también cuentan
[Aplausos]
los partidarios de acabar con la llamada
neutralidad en la red no tienen muy
claro un mercado con mucha competencia
es la mejor garantía para impulsar la
innovación y garantizar un buen servicio
al cliente y aquí amigos una cosa es
cierta internet surgió creció y se
desarrolló fundamentalmente como un
espacio libre sin que existiese esa
regulación que conocemos hoy como
neutralidad en la red fijaos en las
palabras de marc andreessen cofundador
de netscape y personaje clave en el
nacimiento de facebook una visión de una
neutralidad pura en la red es difícil de
sostener si también quieres tener una
inversión continua en redes de banda
ancha si existieran estas normas de
neutralidad pura en la red por las que
no se podría cobrar nunca nada una
empresa como netflix no vas a conseguir
nunca obtener un retorno sobre una
inversión continua en la red lo que
significa que dejará de invertir en la
red y yo no quiero estar durante los
próximos 10 o 20 años con las mismas
velocidades de ancho de banda que
tenemos hoy
es una de las principales críticas que
ha motivado el cambio la regulación des
incentiva a las empresas a invertir algo
que parece claro con las estadísticas en
la mano
[Música]
fijaos como hemos visto antes en los
últimos años el tráfico de internet en
eeuu ha crecido muchísimo sin embargo
sorprendentemente la inversión en
infraestructuras de banda ancha se ha
estancado e incluso reducido en los
últimos años
[Música]
algo que evidentemente no es normal y
que por ejemplo alimenta uno de los
grandes problemas que el sector tiene en
eeuu la falta de competencia en muchas
partes del país
[Música]
pero claro si la regulación dificulta y
reduce la rentabilidad potencial del
negocio los incentivos a invertir
también se reducen sustancialmente es
algo bastante lógico nos parece otro
punto que alegan los partidarios de
acabar con la regulación de obama es que
esta era una regulación que no sólo
perjudicaba la inversión sino que además
era completamente innecesaria
durante casi 20 años internet próspero
bajo el enfoque de una regulación ligera
establecida por el presidente clinton y
un congreso republicano este marco
bipartidista llevó al sector privado a
invertir 15 millones en la construcción
de redes de comunicaciones en todo eeuu
y nos dio una economía de internet que
se convirtió en la envidia del mundo
según alegan estos partidarios en los 20
años anteriores a la conocida como
neutralidad de la red esto es entre 1995
y 2015 el acceso a internet no hizo más
que extenderse y mejorar en velocidad y
calidad
[Música]
durante este tiempo surgieron las
grandes empresas digitales que hoy
conocemos como google facebook netflix o
uber por poner sólo algunos ejemplos de
hecho es curioso pero las operadoras no
han sido las grandes ganadoras del
nacimiento de internet
fijaos tan solo alphabet esto es google
tiene una capitalización un valor en
bolsa que es bastante mayor que el valor
conjunto de las tres mayores operadoras
de telecomunicaciones de eeuu así que
los detractores de la neutralidad de la
red se preguntan por qué cambiará algo
que ha funcionado tan bien desde su
nacimiento cuando una operadora ha
restringido el acceso a un medio de
comunicación o ag mails de hecho la
única vez que ocurrió algo parecido
cuando comcast quiso bloquear las
conexiones p2p para frenar las descargas
ilegales al final tuvo que dar marcha
atrás por la mala publicidad y también
por la presión de las autoridades porque
amigos y este es el tercer punto menos
regulación no implica anarquía de hecho
a partir de ahora en eeuu internet
pasará a estar regulado por la poderosa
comisión federal del comercio que es la
encargada de la política antimonopolio y
además las operadoras tendrán que
cumplir con una estricta política de
transparencia tendrán que comunicar
claramente
cualquier política que restrinja o
favorezca la velocidad de acceso a
cualquier servicio digital la verdad es
que el cielo no se va a caer la comisión
federal del comercio va a ser una
policía enérgica a la hora de patrullar
como ya lo ha sido lo que respecta a los
proveedores de internet de hecho los
defensores de esta reforma ponen dos
ejemplos de como el mercado puede
evolucionar sin la neutralidad uno es el
mercado de telefonía móvil mucho más
competitivo y que siempre ha jugado en
el límite de la legalidad
aquí los usuarios se han visto reducirse
sus tarifas al tiempo que mejoraba el
servicio hoy existen por ejemplo
promociones que incluyen el acceso
ilimitado a servicios como netflix sin
consumo de datos lo que claramente viola
el espíritu de la neutralidad en la red
bien el segundo ejemplo que suelen poner
lo encontramos curiosamente en las
compañías aéreas particularmente en la
compañía jetblue
veréis estas compañías no estaban
sometidas a la neutralidad en la red
pues bien a pesar de ello y de tener un
acuerdo con amazon para priorizar el
consumo de prime vídeo a bordo de sus
aviones decidió libremente no castigar a
otros servicios como hb o por ejemplo
nuestra estrategia para el wifi en vuelo
es ofrecer el mejor servicio al menor
costo a tantos pasajeros como sea
posible así que estamos motivados para
apoyar todo el contenido de una manera
justa y neutral
[Música]
bien
yo sin amigos estamos sin duda ante una
cuestión bastante compleja pero creo de
verdad que se han exagerado bastante las
consecuencias y por supuesto no creo que
estemos ni mucho menos ante el fin de
internet
[Música]
si alguna operadora se excede será
seguro castigada por sus clientes y si
es verdad en gran parte de eeuu hay un
problema serio de competencia porque no
hay mercado para elegir operadora sólo
hay disponibles redes de una o dos
compañías
pero me pregunto si lo que se necesita
para solucionar dicha situación no será
precisamente más inversión y el
desarrollo de nuevas tecnologías como el
5g por ejemplo algo que por fortuna
parece está ya a la vuelta de la esquina
en fin amigos con este vídeo os hemos
querido mostrar las diferentes
posiciones ante un tema tan
controvertido yo personalmente me quedo
con un deseo que internet siga siendo lo
más libre posible pero ahora turno para
ti qué te parece el final de la
neutralidad en la red déjanos tu
respuesta en los comentarios y también
en esta encuesta una vez más gracias a
víctor por ayudarnos a arrojar luz en un
tema tan polémico como siempre si te ha
resultado interesante este vídeo dale al
botón de like un saludo y gracias por
estar ahí
[Música]